WON THAT 8-7 IN A SHOOTOUT
HERE'S THEIR FIRST IN THE
SLOT
COGLIANO THROW
IT, AND IT'S DEFLECTING OP THIS
ONE ANP IN THE
HERTL ON THE RIGHT SIDE THERE A
CHANCES BUT CAN'T PUT IT IN THE
BACK OF THE NET. GOA LAYOFF HAD
LITTLE BIT OF A LAG.
BARABANOV' LOOK AT THE
COYOTES' PUSH HERE
IT'S A FORWARDW CK
TO TORONTO AND PLAYS IN THE NEXT
HERTL AT THE FRONT OF THE NET.
KARLSSON WILL GIVE IT TO
BARABANOV, BUT IT'S REJECTED B,
LITTLE BIT OF STISBEHERE WHO MAT
NICE PASS, AND BACK FROM
GOSTISBEHERE INT EVERYTHING HE D
ON THIS PENALTY KILL TO KEEP THE
PUCK OUT OF THE NE'T GETTIME, AR
GREGOR DID NOT READ THAT PLAY.
AND HE SCORES! WITH A GOOD HEADS
UP RIGHT NET
AND HE GETS IT IN THERE!ST
HUSTLE
IT GOES RIGHT BACK INTO TH